[Music]
in human takeover news Wow
centimeters drought that we would he
just cut me off I was like what thank
you
you mean take over human but just like
me my curiosity I need to know what you
think she's Massa me you know the way I
am I think Human Centipede for some
reason uh that he interjected with can
you tie me up and then I think I strap
me down oh sorry we took over Steve's
insides that's for sure submitted by
why'd you salmon mm-hmm does it make
sense yeah why you mean it's an area
it's like an area in Japan where they're
like these really fatty cow it's like
Inland Empire salmon does that make
sense Empire I need to get the reference
where you put up a funny City in front
of it and I laughs yeah like Palmdale
salmon I mean they're freshwater that
laws there's a river there sounds legit
there's no River River and farmed salmon
they could be anywhere no Japan's robot
hotel lays off half the robots after
they created more work for humans lays
them off like I'm sorry family there's
homeless robots now it's like don't
power me down don't do it I thought you
put institution huh no sex robots yes
sir no robot hotel hotel they give me
that [ __ ] look robots and Japanese
people I'm gonna give you the look but
it's just that because I knew the answer
do you think that sex robots are gonna
get to sit down to where it's like
you're too old I hate new moms that they
I've been having them for a while and
they were just not worth fixing so just
like put it away either you did that for
up the name in the movie but that's
exactly what happened
no no but it was so much like sorry the
new model just does it better
exactly that's what happened in the
movie wow you just unplug them and you
just see them going that's what we do
with our cell phones once the new one
comes out the old one kind of signs will
you like your phone I want that one yeah
I hate my camera anyway this camera is
awesome yeah they have the same phone
you guys have a thing for me what is it
he wanted his own spotlight XS x oh [ __ ]
off is it really XS am no now you [ __ ]
off Apple [ __ ] off what access almond X
digital radio this sound like more than
fine out it's ridiculous it's like uh
makeup gurus talking about their brushes
is like I had them there feedback they
should have it either one's called
iPhone 11 cars confusing - yeah which
cars normal cars have names
4d or some [ __ ] Oh No well that makes
sense gonna talk about the leader size
of the engine I don't care I agree
oh it's a random name like a Tercel I
know what that means I'd rather not like
all these like letters and numbers yeah
it's more confusing for me yeah yeah
because it's like like it's telling you
the size of the engine so then you know
that it's faster but then the route now
you have to memorize these names that
for me is hard like at 3:35 eyes it has
a bigger engine than at 323 ya know
anything about cars anything like at all
ever
yeah you bother memorizing name I want
my keyboard f 150 250 and 350
that's like too much - oh the Sierra de
camiones yeah
are you gonna know which one's the big
yeah that's my homework
no no no the cars not bigger the engine
is bigger I wish it was Volvo ssin so
it's like oh you gonna get a BMW it's
like you want to BMW sadder do you want
to the BMW it's like oh I want the BMW
sad cuz I don't have that much money
okay give them the sad you think the fun
yeah the extremely fun or the
ludicrously extremely fun exactly you
sound like a Tesla like wait do you like
are you you like you came to Honda thank
you they're like do you like camping and
you're like I do like camping I'm like
bring it onto camping and it's like do
you not like camping it's like I don't
like camping and they're like okay don't
bring her back on because they bring her
the Honda not campers yeah there you go
not going anyway
so this took bands strange hotel it has
laid off half of its two hundred and
forty three robots
Wow after they created an ending to each
one and was like thank you for your
services exactly but but they were
responsibly raised and very happy until
they were killed in the end they were
like wait but we didn't just recycle
them right just brush them down in a
robot junkyard we saw you just do that
cuz they're property they're just robots
all right we can't have any emotion for
robots because then they're gonna take
over yeah I remember that one study that
we talked about where there was this
tiny little robot my dad bought I could
that one the same one it's like a white
and blue it's white and blue the one
that begs you knock down pokey yeah it's
the same exact programmers did that on
purpose it was just for the one study
right it's a white and blue robot no
it's not for it's like for
eight-year-old an older but okay I'll
hold on to this phrase you're a
programmer you should make a saying
please I'm trapped in here please I'm a
human that's really good
mirror I found a talisman and it on a
strange dock
I should never have picked it up I
should have never done it I would have
for sure unplug it cuz I don't want me
find my body about the body
it's literally doing that freaked me out
I would just throw it in the oven and
melt that butter you could just by using
our oven oh there are other ways to melt
it fire you grill it
I use my girl what is a fireplace bridge
you don't know we have a fireplace what
do you think your house is walk you know
because you know how Asians are Asians
they go to a place like okay where's the
fireplace
oh there it is let's put a TV in front
of and cover it up drug use that [ __ ] oh
yeah and crispy now covered there's
right forget the salmon but because of
Leia she please no but yak forget that
you live with the [ __ ] Asian person
that does that to your house no but I'm
so used to it I thought maybe we would
have done it together like that a
fireplace is rigged right like there's
like the tiniest houses I've ever seen
that place is the shittiest houses ever
have fireplaces the reason why I said
the size of the house is because it's so
small that you can sit in the middle of
room and see every [ __ ] wall whoa
Jill you're so poor wait how's your new
Tesla do my parents use a fireplace can
I ask how easy
no my family today my friends yeah this
is some kamikaze I will say that my
family never used her fireplace no no
because my parents put a treadmill in
front of it it's not an Asian thing and
your sister just puts a million toys in
front of it yes she does exactly they
don't use that [ __ ] yet she puts a
million in front of you and then sold me
to comment see me to carve it and and
she's like well Jeff just has to buy me
a bigger house yep and then I was like
that's right her husband Jeff so the
problem is not that they have too many
toys for this kid and that they're
hoarding toys a lot of it they don't
have enough room for all my toys Museum
of toys sure you walk in and it's like a
toy store
it's like Elizabeth your mom or is no my
sister's a hoarder as well but she but
it's she's in the early days they had an
episode about hoarders earlier but I
didn't want to out anybody you can out
them my home
these waters we want we're talking about
that I'm not ordering a condo thing and
but yeah my sister is like a diet
hoarder she's like beginning this the
stages of whole thing I'll call it a
diet she's like we don't have enough
toys I'm just saying compared to my
other kids to come over here and think
it's so fun here they got more toys and
Tiger just talked about a lot of toys
I bet the ratio of house to toys a lot
big small place in you yeah it's like
but they filled every [ __ ] room with
toys man like one room is a guest room
and you can't even use it because they
put all the furniture in there so they
could make room for all the toys down so
way that's insane you know putting the
doors like a furniture yeah you can't
sleep in there anymore it's not a guest
room anymore
and then on every in every room the
inside of the room is all layered every
wall with toys every wall Wow with them
we will put there we're [ __ ]
we're like I'm happy to be there's a lot
of toys just one kit or actually she
just had a second kid but he's like a
baby baby so she just turned 3 so now
they're gonna double in three years he
was accumulated that many toys yeah and
they're all like girl toys and you can
chill they're all pink okay their chair
their [ __ ] girl toys now he is gonna
be he's a boy so that means they're
gonna have double the [ __ ] toy boy
toy get the bad news like I mean there's
a whole kitchenette in there he ain't
gonna use the kitchen at really my girl
toys it's not a pink kitchen it's just a
kitchen this is a regular example they
got her a plastic pretend grille thing
and she doesn't even touch it that's for
little dudes yeah well anyway we're
talking about this robot hotel thing
here yeah I have some photos Oh
photos of the hotel yeah did the robots
take them right before they got fired
damn last day like I love working here
clicked all my thing in every room
that's supposed to give it's called
chorizo it's kind of like a theory oh
but it makes you age it makes everything
so much cuter
yeah but they're saying that they is
just causing more work or like the
humans have to do the work anyway
because she can't seem to answer or like
this thing can't seem to answer simple
questions or like what time does the
amusement park closer well it's just
like Siri yeah so but then they can't
complete the task and why would they
unplug him he's great yeah so he's
supposed to be checking people in and
getting their [ __ ] talents he's like
give me your license but he can't do it
and humans have to do it anyway so it's
like she's like do you want the room
with the window non-smoking of smoking I
hope you've got a British accent well no
the dinosaur a British Japanese actor
he's a British dinosaur yeah it could be
a British dinosaur in Japan yeah do you
think in 500 years future humans will
look back on this and think that we did
it right though they're like yeah they
used to have robots doing everything we
don't know what happened the collapse of
the frickin civilisation happen and then
the robots disappeared no I think that
it'll be different because I think
history will be illegal because
everything's [ __ ] offensive in
history so I think history itself will
be illegal I'm not allowed to have
history yeah I don't think human history
is written by the victor so in a sense a
lot of history is a little true
[Music]